zehn milliarden tonnen das ist eine echt
unfassbare zahl und tatsächlich hat ein
forschungsteam vom renommierten
massachusetts institute of technology
jetzt herausgefunden dass die erde in
ihrem inneren mehr als zehn milliarden
tonnen diamanten verbergen könnte
tausendfach mehr als bisher gedacht und
das überrascht auch die
wissenschaftswelt extrem ein riesiger
schatz in der tiefe also direkt unter
unseren füßen war wie kommen wir also
ran klicks um science-fiction hier gibt
es täglich faszinierende wissenschafts
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
diamanten begeistern uns menschen schon
seit langer zeit als edelsteine sind sie
kostbar und sehr beliebt für einen
rohdiamanten aus afrika gab es bei einer
versteigerung erst vor kurzem satte 40
millionen dollar doch rein
wissenschaftlich gesehen handelt es sich
bei diamanten einfach nur um kohlenstoff
der unter hohem druck und unterhitze
komprimiert wurde damit sind sie der
härtesten natürliche stoff auf der welt
urzeitliche vulkane haben sie dann
irgendwann einmal aus der tiefe des
erdmantels nach oben befördert und für
uns menschen zugänglich gemacht meistens
entstehen sie in bis zu 200 kilometern
tiefe und die besonders großen unter
ihnen sogar noch tiefer in der erde
konkret entstehen diamanten in den
sogenannten kronen das sind die quasi
die kontinent wurzeln die rund 300
kilometer in den erdmantel hineinragen
man kann sie sich vorstellen wie
umgekehrte berge die tief in den
erdmantel hineinreichen es sind die
ältesten und unbeweglich ssten
gesteinsschichten die unter dem zentrum
der meisten kontinent platten liegen um
die spitzen der kantone ging es auch dem
forschungsteam des massachusetts
institute of technology
denn wenn seismische wellen diese karten
wurzeln passieren werden sie immer
schneller rund 4,7 kilometer pro sekunde
doch dieses hohe tempo lässt sich
seltsamerweise nicht mit dem dort
vorhandenen gesteins komponenten
erklären ein großes rätsel also für die
fachwelt kurz zum hintergrund
prinzipiell können seismische empfänger
auf der ganzen welt wellen aufzeichnen
die durch tsunamis
fusionen oder erdbeben entstehen die
wellen sind unterschiedlich schnell
je nach zusammensetzung dichte und
temperatur des gesteins durch dass sie
sich bewegen umgekehrt können
forschungsteams aber eben auch durch das
tempo der wellen rekonstruieren welche
art gestein die wellen passiert haben
müssen
in ihrer studie haben die us
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
seismische messdaten mit einem
virtuellen experiment verknüpft sie
erstellten virtuelle karten wurzeln und
analysierten in einer simulation wie
schnell sich beben wählen ja sich dort
fortbewegen und zwar je nachdem welche
tests gesteine sie in ihrem modell
eingesetzt hatten ihr ergebnis die
karten wurzeln bestehen zu knapp 80
prozent aus dem gestein periode und zu
20 prozent aus ethno geht dabei handelt
es sich um ein baltisches umwandlungs
gestein zudem gab es aber die riesige
überraschung ein bis zwei prozent der
karten wurzeln müssen auch aus diamant
bestehen das sind umgekehrt wohl mehr
als zehn milliarden tonnen das ist wie
gesagt tausendfach mehr als man bisher
lang dachte dazu einer der beteiligten
forscher ulrich foul von m
das ist zwar nur einen indizienbeweis
aber wir sind alle möglichkeiten
durchgegangen und dies ist das einzige
das als plausible erklärung übrig
geblieben ist der gehalt von 1 bis 2%
diamant passe nicht nur zu den
geologischen parametern sondern erkläre
auch das hohe tempo der scherben
diese erkenntnis ist tatsächlich neu und
zeigt uns dass diamanten gar nicht so
selten sind wie häufig angenommen
allerdings nur geologisch gesehen
denn eine möglichkeit diesen schatz zu
erreichen die gibt es nicht das große
problem dabei die diamanten liegen bis
zu 240 kilometer tief unter der
erdoberfläche und das können selbst die
tiefsten bohrungen nicht leisten 994
hatte man mit einem rollen bohrmeißel
rund 9100 meter geschafft also etwas
mehr als neun kilometer weltrekord was
an derart senkrechtes tiefes loch in die
erdkruste angeht kornkreise im meer was
steckt dahinter draufklicken anschauen
und die neugier zone abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran